it's hard to sort of judge what the
exact impact has been on public
awareness because how do you measure
public awareness of an idea so ground
report has certainly brought attention
to a lot of issues that people otherwise
never would have heard of but it's hard
to see how that translates into
something at the other end we've had a
lot of nonprofits for instance writing
under the name of their nonprofit
published reports and later on they were
eventually able to you know gain key
legislation one interesting example is
my my hometown of Dobbs Ferry was able
to get a historical distinction from
from Congress for being one of the sites
that George Washington visited on on you
know on his campaign and they had
published the the local historian it
published numerous research reports and
updates proving this so those are a
couple of examples of you know I don't
know if there's a direct causation there
but certainly certainly it contributed
then we have other issues where we've
seen more humanitarian based results
that are really wonderful so for
instance we have a we have a an Afghani
reporter who reported on a young woman
about I think 16 or 17 who was attacked
by her husband who she was married to
through an arranged marriage I think he
was in his 60s or 70s and she was
disfigured and she was burned with acid
and it was really terrible and
unfortunately this is a fairly common
story but because it was on ground
report because it was on an
english-language source the reporter was
contacted by an aid organization that
ended up covering all of the medical
medical costs and I didn't even hear
about this until like a month after it
took place and I and I noticed because
the reporter had put the follow-up
report on ground report and so the other
thing we do is we just we allow people
to connect amongst themselves and not
just pushing one overall agenda but we
allow all these little connections to
happen that in little ways help help to
improve society
I think the biggest thing that I've
learned because I was coming at this not
from a media or journalism background I
was coming at Ground report from a
diplomacy and international relations
and a technology background is the
incredible importance of the trusted
human network so we can create these
algorithms that build wonderful looking
virtual newspapers but without the human
input it really doesn't work because you
can't get a computer to to put stories
together at least not yet in a way that
that really works and it's also
something that translates to your
community and I mean not just your
audience but you're contributing
community so if we just when we add
ground report just had this algorithm
that was choosing the stories and
publishing it wasn't really enough once
we built this team of volunteer
Wikipedia style editors who could go in
any piece of content the suddenly the
platform felt like it was alive and it
really translated in the behavior of our
contributors who took themselves much
more seriously they realize this is this
is an active thing and there are people
on the other end who really care about
what we're doing so i would actually
take sort of the opposite slant of what
so many of my peers say and say it's the
human network is so incredibly important
that we need to really focus on on that
aspect and also a lot of a lot of the
things that go along with that like
vetting and fact-checking